ceptin Delma was a writer who created
black propaganda on behalf of the
British government and used fake news to
fight the Nazi regime through postcards
court documents and pirate radio
programs Delma and the rest of the
Secret Service infiltrated the minds of
the German people using elements of
violence sex and death in their stories
to suddenly break down the morale of the
Nazis so who was Sefton Delma and why
was he most likely the only man on earth
who could have become the true master of
black propaganda
[Music]
Denis Sefton Dharma was born in 1904 in
Berlin Germany as a child everyone
called him Tom but as an adult everyone
remembered him by his parents conjoins
last names and he was known as Sefton
Dalma his father frederick Sefton Dalma
taught English at Berlin University his
parents were both from Australia and
they had Jewish heritage they registered
his birth at the British Consulate so
that he could be a dual citizen he only
spoke a German before the age of five
which his parents chose to do on purpose
hoping he would blend in better he grew
up to become bilingual in both English
and German but his parents still raised
him to understand his Australian
ancestry at home at the start of World
War one his father Frederick was removed
from his position as a professor at the
University because he was the so called
enemy alien and he was forced to live in
the rule of been internment camp growing
up in Germany the other children in
school labelled him as an enemy and he
was isolated from his peers and bullied
for being different even though they
were exactly the same
in 1917 Frederick was released from a
camp through a prisoner exchange program
between the British and the Germans but
instead of going back to Australia the
whole family was deported to England so
Sefton dama was able to transfer to a
school in London since German was his
first language he couldn't help but
speak with an accent as far as his
English classmates were concerned though
he was considered the enemy once again
and he was also isolated from the other
children in the school even though this
must have been difficult this life of
being stuck in between two worlds is
precisely why he was able to understand
both cultures so completely since he was
ostracized for the sound of his voice or
the words that he used it only made him
pay more attention to those details and
this would all come rather in handy
later on in his adult life World War one
ended in 1918 when Sefton Delmer was 14
years old
despite the fact that he had endured so
much bullying in his younger years he
still embraced the fact that he was
bilingual he went on to study at Oxford
University where he studied German
possibly to follow in his father's
footsteps of securing a job as a
professor
however the never did start a teaching
career he instead chose to fully embrace
the other passion in his life and that
was writing and this this was just the
beginning of his destiny
[Music]
after graduating from Oxford University
Sefton Delma got a job for a magazine
called The Daily Express since he was
bilingual he became very valuable to the
magazine and translating the news coming
out of Germany in order to make the
British public aware he was able to
become friendly with the Nazi officer
and Strom who introduced him to a doff
Hitler in 1932 at this time Hitler had
just lost his first election and he
wouldn't become the Chancellor of
Germany until 1933
Sefton dalla was able to travel with
Hitler on his private plane and listen
to all of his plans for what he wanted
for Germany he became the first British
journalist who ever secured an interview
with that of Hitler and he traveled to
Berlin to report the day when he took
office in 1933 this may seem like a
monumental event that should have set
him off right then and there but at the
time no one would ever predict that
Hitler would become this evil dictator
he was promising to bring Germany out of
the financial hardships that didn't
endured after World War one and he was
even given the title of Man of the Year
in Time magazine so as far as The Daily
Express was concerns there were far more
important things going on elsewhere the
same year The Daily Express sent him to
France to work out of their offices in
Paris at that time Paris was the place
to be for some of the most creative
people in history some of the most
famous writers of their time were living
and working there in the late 1920s to
the early 1930s and many of them were
actually friends with one another as
well these writers they were the
so-called lost generation and they
indulged heavily in drugs sex and jazz
while in Paris Sefton Delma met and fell
in love with a woman named Isabelle
Nicolas she was a very successful artist
designer and model she was quite
beautiful and she became the muse for
several famous painters and sculptors
including Pablo Picasso in a lot of ways
they were a perfect match for one
another and in 1935 the two were married
a couple of years later Sefton Delma
became a correspondent during the
Spanish Civil War which lasted from 1936
to 1939 General Francisco Franco was
trying to take over the Spanish
government's on behalf of fascism at
both Nazi Germany and Italy were sending
money and ammunition to Franco's army
service and our became good friends
with Hemingway who was there writing for
scripts and doing the voiceover for a
documentary called the Spanish earth
another writer Martha Gellhorn was also
there for Colliers magazine she was one
of the only female war correspondents
she was also willing to put her life in
danger to get the scoop on a story she
would later actually marry Hemingway
making her his third wife a large group
of these writers photographers and
filmmakers they lived together in the
hotel Florida in Madrid and they were
often singing and drinking in the hotel
lobby and bar they all believed that by
covering the events of the Spanish Civil
War they could shed light on the fact
that a LOF Hitler was already pushing
his fascist regime on the rest of the
world and that the Nazis were indeed
very dangerous but these writers would
have no idea that soon enough their own
countries would be at war as well and
there was nothing that they could do to
stop it
[Music]
on the brink of World War two secret
agents and spies were commonplace
throughout Europe Her Majesty's Secret
Service was paying close attention to
anyone that they believed could be a
Nazi sympathizer including Sefton delma
it was like he was living through his
elementary school experience all over
again because the Germans believed that
he was an agent for mi6 and they no
longer allowed him to interview Adolf
Hitler or any other high-ranking members
of the Nazi Party it was only after he
returned to London and started working
for the German branch of the BBC that
the British government knew that they
could actually trust him Sefton delma
once described one of had all Hitler's
speeches as coming from his lying
stinking teeth well that's not exactly
the most professional thing a journalist
could say of the air it actually did
work out very well for him because in
1940 he was recruited by the political
warfare executive branch or the pwe for
short and that time the British Secret
Service was very concerned about a
private radio program called workers
challenge which was broadcasting from
inside of the UK but it was actually a
German propaganda show run by talented
actors who spoke fluent English
they were posing as an anti-war program
and they spread fake news to bring down
the morale of the British troops the
British government asked Dumberer to
make his own version of a radio show
that was black propaganda the goal was
to give out roughly 80% real facts but
try to slip in 20% fake news that was
meant to subvert the Germans he
wholeheartedly agreed to do the job at
his wife Isabelle was excited to help in
whatever way she could in 1941 the
government gave him a requisitioned
country house in Bedfordshire where he
worked together with a team on creating
propaganda Isabelle Illustrated fake
postcards of German soldiers with French
prostitutes this was meant to make
Frenchmen angry and jealous and
inherently dislike the Nazis at that
time there's Abele's illustrations they
were sexy and suggestive but they were
not exactly pornographic I mean this was
the early 20th century serfdom Dahmer
started a radio broadcast and he wrote
scripts under the alias of der chef
he hired a German immigrants an actor
named Paul Saunders to be the voice of
the character he spoke with a perfect
Berlin accent and they had a strong
enough radio tower to make it seem as if
the show was being broadcast from
Germany
- effort claims to be a loyal not seein
that he was simply giving insider
information to inform his fellow
comrades he used coarse language and
spoke out against the enemies of the
Third Reich since Dalma grew up in
Germany he knew how to write these words
as if they were truly coming from a
German person and no one would ever know
that the show was actually produced by
the English septons Alma had a great
sense of humor and he knew how to
capture an audience's attention much of
the fake news that he wrote included
sectional stories which was enough to
keep the audience listening on a regular
basis for example he once wrote that the
British were trying to get German
prisoners of war to give up their
secrets by tying them up and torturing
them with strippers - chef urged them to
be strong and not to give in to
temptation
Saunders would have to tell these
stories as if he were outraged at the
English saying don't give in to these
perversions say nothing then once he had
their attention he would go on to tell
fake news that was secretly meant to
demoralize the enemy
Sefton Zeller was also a part of the
government's underground propaganda
committee it was their job to collect
rumors that were already spreading in
German communities and used those as the
basis of the fake news by using this
strategy they were simply confirming
what people were already whispering
about so it was far easier for the
audience to believe that what was being
said was true along with that show
Sefton Dalma wrote ends produced a
second radio program called Atlantic
sender which was meant to seduce German
soldiers they played jazz music which
had been forbidden to German citizens a
female actress called Agnes Bernal who
they called Vicki read the scripts in
her sultry voice together with another
writer and spy Ian Fleming Delma put
together stories that were basically
erotic fan fiction of various fantasy
scenarios between German men and English
women these stories worked exactly as he
had hoped a former German officer named
horse Brito said that he would listen to
Atlantic senator with the rest of the
men who was stationed in a u-boat once
he saw how truly beautiful the actress
was he asked for a copy of her photo and
joked if there were TVs onboard the
u-boats and we saw these pictures a lot
of them would say the war is finished
let's go home and be with English girls
of course not every arm was a fan of
these sexy stories a politician named
Sir Stafford Cripps got a hold of an
english translation of the der chef
broadcast the particular script he read
was
dirty story about an audience Crips was
disgusted by how crude they were he
wrote if this is how we win the war I'd
rather lose it despite receiving this
criticism that show was able to continue
the black propaganda team had really
figured out what made men Tekken's their
subversive messages manipulating them
through sexual desires and fantasies was
actually working very well years later
after the war was won delmas co-writer
Ian Fleming had a light bulb moments if
the German soldiers would go crazy
fantasizing over these characters so
with the rest of the men in the world he
continued to write these sexy stories
only this time the main character was a
British spy whose adventures were based
on his own experiences during the war he
wrote pop fiction novels about his
alter-ego James Bond
Delmas wife Isabelle would later say
that they were both having the time of
their lives creating this propaganda she
thought it was hilarious that the
government was essentially paying her to
draw pornography for a living they
recruited some of the most talented
artists in the country to come and join
the team and Sefton Dalma had his own
sense of humor for initiating new
recruits
a 22 year old artist named Marion White
on was asked to join the secret
organization there were several British
generals there on the dev a briefing
they were all wearing their uniforms
without even a hint of a smile on their
faces dorama said that if she told
anyone about the secret mission they
were about to give her she would be sent
to jail and suffer 10 years of hard
labour she nervously agreed and he slid
a postcard of Adolf Hitler
across the table the postcard was titled
with the German phrase what we have we
hold the first assignment was to tamper
the postcard so it looked as if Hitler
was holding his own penis in his hand
decades later Marion why Tom told this
story during an interview for a
documentary
she said that looking back she could
have laughed but the atmosphere of the
room was so serious she simply agreed to
do the duty for our country as she left
the room to get started Sefton Delma
called out but not too big Marion
meanwhile in Germany the Nazi minister
of propaganda Joseph Goebbels had an
entirely different strategy instead of
using subtle and creative writing he was
loud and confidently stated bold lies
about how the Jews were to blame that
Germany's hardships for a population of
people who were desperate they clung on
to the idea that they could blame the
Jews for the economic problems of
Germany as time went on it became clear
to Sefton Dalma and his team that
writing
subtle jokes and sexy stories was not
going to be enough to win the war so
there to get darker Delmas team was able
to find the exact typeface used in
official German documents this way they
created fake court records and leaked
them to the public
all of these fictional court cases were
made to have the SS officers guilty of
rape and murder
he wrote excruciating details of the
story only to have them acquitted of all
charges by the end this was obviously
meant to outrage anyone who read the
documents and it made the Nazi
government look like complete monsters
he wrote these to try to convince the
German people that they were fighting
for an evil and corrupt government in
1943 decided that he wanted to stop the
Dersch F broadcast but he knew that his
character would never actually stop his
radio broadcast and less he was forced
to so he wrote and staged a scene where
Nazi soldiers came through the door to
his studio and shot him while he was
live on earth he hopes that if Nazi
soldiers were out there listening they
would realize that there was no such
thing as freedom of the press in a
fascist government
[Music]
the longer the war went on the higher
the stakes became they felt that it was
necessary to mess with the minds of
German men in the darkest way a lot of
the information that was given to the
black propaganda writers came from
highly skilled British intelligence
agency were interrogating captured Nazi
soldiers whatever a Nazi soldier refused
to say anything about his top-secret
information they would try to get him to
relax and talk about his personal life
instead without realizing it these
soldiers were giving up information
about the bases where they were staying
the bars where German soldiers drank and
so on so since the names and details
given out about the men on the radio
were accurate they believed there must
be a spy among them who was giving away
all of their information this made the
Germans distrust one another and it was
difficult for them to form a close bond
with their comrades they would read out
the names of streets that had been
apparently bombed in Berlin and Hamburg
even if they hadn't they purposefully
figured out where German new bombers
lived so that they could read out these
specific addresses of all the men who
were on the boats this would make the
soldiers fall into a state of depression
and anxiety and completely ruin them are
all many of those German soldiers would
go through the rest of the war feeling
like they had nothing to fight for
the British also drops photographs of
dead women and children over German
bases which made them wonder if their
own wives and children were among the
debt many of these men would be in the
shock of their lives to go home and find
out that their family was still very
much alive
the Germans chose to do the same sort of
propaganda only with the strategy to
make the Allied soldiers want to end the
war and go home they played on men's
jealousies with a sultry female voice
playing over the radio asking if they
knew what their wives and girlfriends
were doing without them by the time the
Americans joined the war German planes
were dropping leaflets of fake life
magazines featuring photographs of nude
women on one side and death with skull
wearing a helmet on the other there was
also one leaflet that said gentlemen
prefer blondes but blondes don't like
cripples with the picture of an American
veteran a beauty all of these dark
campaigns led to Sefton delmas most
heartless project yes it was called the
dead letters British intelligence were
able to intercept letters written to
German soldiers who had actually died
many of them were from concerned mothers
saying that they had not heard from
their son's in a while and they hoped
that they were safe if British
intelligence
managed to intercept those letters Delma
could write back to these families
claiming that the men were in hiding and
would soon be home at first this sounds
like he was actually being kind to these
German families but after reading enough
of these letters over the radio the
German soldiers who heard the broadcasts
would hear the names of the men they saw
dying in front of their eyes they knew
that someone was lying and they believed
that the dead letters were coming from
the German government during these dark
times
Sefton delmas wife Isabel could not take
it any longer she resented Delma 'thou
cruelly was being to his fellow human
beings war or not the propaganda wasn't
funny anymore
she couldn't handle having any part of
us and they ended up getting divorced
the war had left its scars and Isabel
would go through two more marriages
before the end of her life after World
War two Sefton Delma returned to his job
at The Daily Express he published a
novel called black boomerang in 1962 but
beyond that he lived out a quiet
retirement sworn to secrecy he never
fully revealed the details of his time
creating black propaganda until the
1970s when enough time had passed and he
was able to finally talk about his
experiences in his autobiography the
counterfeit spy today few people
remember Sefton demo or how he was a
voice of opposition for the German
people who were used to hearing the loud
lies of Adolf Hitler and Joseph girls
while we may never know just how many
people heard his broadcasts we do know
that his work was one of the many
elements that helped the Allies win the
war so I really hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
give us a thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe got brand new videos just like
this every day of the week if you'd like
to check out something else that I do
right now though why not check out my
other channel called day I found out I'm
gonna link to that below as well as on
the screen now and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]